if you pursue the materialist dream it
doesn't fulfill you whereas if you use
that for the purposes of saying I can do
something to help others you're going to
benefit yourself as well as others
my guest today is just an absolute
living legend his name is Peter Singer
and he is perhaps the world's most
influential living philosopher if you
were hiding a Jewish Family in your
Cellar in Nazi Germany and the Gestapo
came to your door you know if you can
save the family you're hiding by telling
a lie to the Gestapo obviously you
should do that the grandfather of both
the modern animal rights and effective
altruism movements Peter is a professor
of bioethics a Princeton and Laureate
professor at the University of Melbourne
he's published several books on our
moral responsibility to alleviate
suffering including the highly
influential book animal Liberation and
the life you can save both of which are
books we cover in this conversation to
live in ethical life it's not enough
just to say I'm going to obey some
simple moral rules you have to think
also about what can I do positively
given the advantages that I have and the
problems that we have in the world
Peter has very generously offered to
provide everybody with a free copy of
his book the life you can save to anyone
who wants one to get your copy visit
thelifeyoucansave.org Rich Roll or click
the link in the description below and
the point that I'm really driving at is
that donations to Peter's save lives
fund can also be made by this link and
all donations there will be matched
dollar for dollar up to twenty five
thousand dollars thanks to a very
generous Anonymous donor the a lot of
people in extreme poverty we're damaging
the climate of our planet we're
inflicting vast amounts of suffering on
non-human animals in factory farms there
are all sorts of choices that you have
to make about how you're going to live
what do you eat all of those things that
we can now see as ethical questions it
was an absolute honor to host this
discussion so without further Ado here's
me and Peter Singer
um well Peter it's a real honor to have
you here uh today as somebody who's
admired your work for a very long time
I'm thrilled with the prospect of being
able to talk to you and this
conversation will be have have been
preceded by me giving an introduction to
your work your kind of formal bio but
I'm curious how you uh articulate what
it is that you do like how do you
explain uh your kind of uh focus and and
curiosity in the world right uh so I've
got interested in philosophy as an
undergraduate but I was always
interested in the part of philosophy
that connects to real life and that can
make a difference to how we live
so some of the courses I did were
discussing how we know anything about
the world how do we know that we're
sitting at a table now that I'm not
dreaming that there's not an evil demon
who's given me Illusions uh those are
interesting intellectual problems but I
certainly wouldn't have wanted to spend
my life doing them
um but once I realized that
ethics the part of philosophy that
connects with life really can make a
difference to
how you think about uh your life your
values and how you act in the world
makes a difference to changing the world
uh and that seemed to me to be something
important and worthwhile as well as
intellectually interesting yeah I mean
what's interesting is that you have
fulfilled that promise in an era and a
time in which there does seem to be
a disconnect between
um the kind of academic pursuit of
philosophy and the true utility of it
this came up in your in your
conversation with Ryan holiday where he
was saying back in you know ancient
Greece and ancient Rome politics and
philosophy were were very uh commingled
Pursuits uh whereas now they don't
really seem to meet but I look at you as
somebody who's had a profound impact on
on culture and how we think about ethics
and Morality In a very utilitarian and
and real way that's true although I
think I've been fortunate in that in the
period that I've been living and working
in philosophy it has moved back more
like that Greek uh ideal if you like
that um
it does connect with how we live and
there are many of my students for
example who are interested in taking
philosophy courses precisely for that
reason they want to think about these
issues and that's different from when I
was an undergraduate when there was
still this period of what was known as
ordinary language philosophy or
linguistic analysis where a lot of
philosophers said philosophy doesn't
teach you how to live it simply helps us
to understand the meanings of the moral
terms
and then the student movement of the
1960s started to get things back on
track
um so with the Vietnam War
students wanted more relevant courses
and one of the things that philosophy
could do was well there's this ancient
tradition of when is it right to go to
war of just War Theory and they started
talking about that and then they started
talking about Civil Disobedience when
are you justified in disobeying the law
and so I think then philosophy got back
on track to those sorts of topics and
and moved away from the idea that
somehow a neutral activity telling you
what it means to say something is good
or bad
yeah I I feel that that that era was
sort of supplanted by you know the greed
is good uh sensibility of the 80s and
and perhaps the unwee of of uh and the
cynicism of of Gen X which is my
generation but I too look at this newer
generation uh the population the age
range of of the students I'm sure you
teach who do seem very concerned about
um ethics morality and impact in terms
of where they're investing their
academic curiosity and and their career
choices like they really want to
um be on a track that is going to have a
net positive on the world which is very
different from the sensibility of my
generation when we were in college
there are always some at least you know
I've been teaching at Princeton now
since 1999 and I think there were always
some students who were interested in how
they could have an impact on the world
but I agree that it's it's come back
more strongly in the in the last few
years and there are more students
wanting to take courses for that reason
which of course begs the question of how
do we think about morality positive
impact ethics Etc so when the question
is posited to you you know what does it
mean to live an ethical life how do you
begin to unpack that and respond to it
in a meaningful way that that can help
direct somebody who's you know wanting
to know the answer to that yeah so I
asked them to think about the impact
that they can have about the
consequences of their actions uh what
they can do to make the world a better
place than it would have been if they
hadn't lived in it and clearly there are
a lot of opportunities for that I mean
especially if you're living in an
affluent society like the United States
or any of the other affluent countries
and you see that there are a lot of
people in extreme poverty in other
countries you see that we're damaging
the climate of our planet you see that
we're inflicting vast amounts of
suffering on non-human animals in
factory farms there are all sorts of
choices that you have to make about how
you're going to live uh what you're
going to do as a career choice which
students are thinking about but also uh
what are you doing with your spare cash
um what do you eat all of those things
are we can now see as ethical questions
so for me to live in ethical life it's
not enough just to say I'm going to obey
some simple moral rules like don't still
steal don't cheat don't don't hurt other
people
um you have to think also about what can
I do positively given the advantages
that I have and the problems that we
have in the world and and your
particular lens for that is the
reduction of suffering that seems to be
kind of like the lever through which all
of this calculus is made yes that's
right um it's it's primarily the
reduction of suffering I do think that
producing happiness a pleasure is is a
value as well but that's a harder thing
to get your hands around right exactly
yes that's right it's it's often easier
to see how you can relieve suffering
than how you can boost happiness and so
you know some people say you should be a
negative utilitarian and only focus on
reducing pain and suffering
um I don't think that's right at least
theoretically it's not right because if
you could greatly increase the happiness
of large number of people uh and do that
without causing any suffering or maybe
cause you know mild head thanks to a few
people clearly that would be the right
thing to do so it's not that it's not
that the positive doesn't count at all
in the scales it's just that given the
way the world is uh the negative the
pain and suffering is so much more
apparent and
in a way so much easier to prevent in
the sense that we know what we could do
that would prevent it maybe hard to
bring that about but sometimes in terms
of making people happier we don't even
really know how to do that right right
and in the in the context of the
reduction of suffering this is this is
kind of the you know the the landscape
from which you're thinking on animal
Liberation emanates and I want to get to
that but I kind of want to put that
aside for now
um and and and focus on something that's
a little bit more current which is the
the you know you being this this sort of
Godfather of the effect of altruism
movement a movement which is very much
in the news at the moment as a result of
Sam bankman freed and FTX and all of
that which has kind of put this uh you
know this idea about how to effectively
give to you know have the greatest
impact on the reduction of suffering
under the microscope of people who are
who are now critical of it and I'm
interested I know you've written about
this but parsing the behavior of this
human being from the philosophical
underpinnings of this movement that you
helped pioneer
yeah
um so
I think
the effect of altruism movement in
general is saying we should
try to make a positive difference the
world as I've been saying and we should
use reason and evidence to find the best
way of doing that
and
one of the things that movement has
talked about is uh
making a positive difference doesn't
necessarily mean becoming a doctor and
working in a low-income country or
working for one of the Charities that
are helping people in poverty uh it
might mean actually trying to earn a lot
of money and then using that to support
organizations that are doing good
um
that can be a a valuable thing to do and
I think
um sand bankman freed set out to do that
I know that he had a conversation with
Will mccaskill early on
um will being one of the founders of the
effective altruism movement and will
suggested that because he was
mathematically gifted that might be an
opportunity for him and I know others
I've had for instance students who were
in a similar situation who've done that
and have given a lot of money to
effective causes so it certainly can be
a good thing to do
um but Sam I think it was obviously
uniquely successful in accumulating a
huge amount of wealth doing that and
became a kind of a poster child in that
way for earning to give
but he was clearly also a huge risk
taker
um and somebody who was prepared to
break standard rules of of how you do
business and uh how you look after other
people's money that's entrusted to you
uh and I think that's what brought about
his downfall the fact that he took risks
they didn't all come off he tried to
patch it off with shifting his customers
trust funds basically to his research uh
investment sort of fund and uh clearly
he shouldn't have done that and I don't
think anybody in the effective altruism
movement thought that the idea of
earning money to to give to good causes
would lead to somebody so flagrantly
this is alleged I suppose we should say
um but uh if if the charges are correct
I don't think anybody in effective
altruism movement thought that anybody
would so flagrantly uh violate those
basic rules of of sound practice and
ethical practice right well you know his
misdeeds and malfeasance will be you
know adjudicated but from the outside
looking in it doesn't look great and I
think uh you know just kind of back up
for a minute effective altruism being
this this this Movement whereby we try
to sort of reduce the amount of
emotional attachment we have to
philanthropic ends and look at it from a
purely objective point of view to to
understand the best use of every dollar
given to have the Maximum Impact in
terms of the reduction of suffering and
and and and those Outlets often aren't
the sexy ones or the ones that we feel
emotionally attached to because we have
a relative who's suffering from a
certain disease it happens to be things
like malaria attention and the like that
can that are cheap easy solutions that
end up saving a lot of lives
um and in the case of of of sand Bank
Sam bankman freed uh I see a guy who
whose motives are in question like it
there is an argument that perhaps he
leveraged this movement because it
looked good from a from a sort of PR
perspective to say that he was an
effective altruist and I'm not sure so
sure like how much money he actually
ended up giving he gave money to lots of
different places and so this sort of
critique of the movement is that it sets
in place uh
unhealthy incentives whereby The end
justifies the means right like no matter
what end uh or what means you pursue to
accumulate a certain amount of wealth
it's okay because this these that those
resources will be deployed in an
altruistic manner
yeah um as for his original motives
um I'm prepared to believe that he did
sit at on that career in order to be
able to give
um I think you know that's that's the
evidence early on that it wasn't wasn't
right from the start he thought oh I'll
pretend to be an effective altruist
because that'll make me more successful
personally
um and figures that I've seen you know
he certainly gave well over 100 million
dollars to effective Charities now
that's not very much when you're worth
20 25 billion that's true but I think he
was
on track to do a lot more he also gave
political donations and some of those
were directed towards making the world
safer for example he supported a
candidate who was an expert on pandemics
because he believed that the US is not
doing nearly enough for pandemic
preparation and I think that's obviously
true
so um uh I I don't think that it was
always just a cover but it may be that
he got carried away with his success and
didn't want to admit for example that
he'd taken a big hit because of a bad
investment from Alameda and so tried to
cover that up whereas you know if he'd
admitted that maybe Alameda had gone
bankrupt he would have still been
wealthy and wouldn't be facing jail so
uh I think that's probably what went
wrong but um in terms of what you were
asking about uh the idea that The end
justifies the means I think people are
often very simplistically say oh well
you know he thought that the ends
Justified the means and they don't but
if you stop and think about it
I think everybody thinks that sometimes
the end does justify the means and the
classic example of that is you know if
you're if you're hiding a Jewish Family
in your Cellar in Nazi Germany and the
Gestapo came to your door
um and you might think normally it's
wrong to tell lies including telling
lies to the state authorities is clearly
wrong but uh you know if you can save
the family you're hiding by telling a
lie to the Gestapo obviously you should
do that so so the question isn't do the
ends ever justify the means the question
is when do the end ends justify the
means
um when are the means too bad or when is
the risk too great or the means not
sufficient uh and you have to look at
those on a on a case-by-case basis right
so that would play out in terms of a
young person pondering career choices
they could either
uh uh uh you know go to the 80 000 hours
website and look at certain types of
impacts oriented careers or they could
become a investment banker and try to
accumulate as much wealth as possible
for the purposes of of deploying that at
a later time and and and from your
perspective both of those are
meritorious and and worthy of
consideration
yes that's right um and in fact if they
go to 80 000 hours there's a lot of
other things that they could do as well
um they could one of the careers
suggested is becoming a research
scientist working in areas that will
make a difference to people in extreme
poverty
um another is to go into politics
politics needs more people who are
really serious about helping people in
poverty doing something about climate
change
um so there's a lot of different options
that people can have and uh in fact the
effective altruism movement did make
quite a thing about only to give in the
early days I think partly because that
was a novelty and it was something that
got media attention and when the
movement was small it was important to
get media attention for for new ideas so
uh will mccaskill in particular you know
made quite a feature of this but um more
recently and but before uh the FTX
collapse and so not specifically related
to Sam bankman freed
um but I have reduced the emphasis that
they put on that partly because of the
idea that one of the problems with new
organizations that have great ideas
um about changing the world in the right
direction is that it's hard for them to
get enough talented people working for
them so smart people like Sam
might now be more likely to be you know
might be suggested that they go into
helping one of these startups
um to really get organized and to scale
up and really make a big difference uh
rather than to earn to give just because
of the the sense that it's not always
lack of Financial Resources it may be
lack of talented people that are slowing
things down
yeah it's interesting
um
in thinking about you know the pursuit
of an ethical life and as somebody who
you know who's who is a you know a moral
philosopher
why is it like
why is this important is there a
morality that exists uh that is that is
a certain kind of like you there's a
universality to that truth that I mean
you're an atheist right so so from
whence does you know this sense of right
and wrong
um and and pursuing an ethical life from
from where does that derive
uh yes I I am an IPS so obviously I
don't I don't think it derives from God
or any god-given commands but uh and for
quite a while I I didn't think there was
an objective truth
um that was postparted the era in which
I was educated in studying philosophy a
lot of philosophers didn't think there
was
um and there has been a a shift for a
number of philosophers and I'm one of
them towards the idea that no there are
some things that we can really see as
self-evidently uh good or often more to
the points of evidently bad so for
example
um when somebody experiences Agony if if
a child uh is going through Agony
um whether it's an illness or an injury
or some malevolent person deliberately
hurting them
um that's just a bad thing and uh the
universe would be a better place if that
child were not experiencing Agony so uh
I think from the self-evidence of of
that judgment and the self-evidence of
the feeling we have ourselves when we
experience severe pain that um that's a
bad thing we can generalize that to
other sentient beings any being who can
experience Agony it's better if they
don't
um and only being who can experience a
enjoyable happy Blissful worthwhile kind
of Life fulfilling life for them uh it's
better if they can
and how how are you making judgments
adjudicating better and good
you know what I mean like like if this
is not uh emanating from some kind of
spiritual connection
you know even in a non-dogmatic
non-religious way uh it's curious to
ponder you know the origin point of why
the world is better if we do this versus
that but I think we we can see that in
our own case we we you know when we
experience agony
we just can't avoid seeing that as a bad
thing for us and then when we
take a broader point of view
um the 19th century utilitarian Henry
Sedgwick spoke about taking the point of
view of the Universe
um and he he was an agnostic really
rather than atheist but he he wasn't
saying you know that the Universe has a
point of view he was just saying imagine
that you're
looking on the universe as a whole and
all the sentient beings in it then you
can see that your own interests your own
well-being is no more important from
that perspective than that of any other
being who can have similar kinds of
experiences of pain or pleasure and so
uh we should as rational beings we
should try to reduce the pain and Agony
that is experienced and increase the
pleasure and happiness because that's
what we want for ourselves and we see
that we are just one of many similar
beings who have those experiences so
much of your work is is focused on the
the responsibility of the individual
like should I give money to this versus
that uh should I not eat animals like
all of these sort of choices
um
that can guide us towards you know kind
of a more ethical way of living
um but we live in a culture in which
incentives and kind of momentum is
pushing us
away from the kind of uh economy of
making those choices in other words like
those choices tend to kind of cut
against the grain of you know what
everything else is pushing us towards
and so
I can't help but think about incentive
structures at large and how your work
being so focused on the individual
um how you contemplate like system
change like governmental regimes or uh
you know economic tectonic plates that
you know set up situations where we're
often making the wrong choice versus
creating a new system in which the
choices that you're advocating for
become the easier kind of more
accessible and more incentivized choice
right well
I certainly want to see changes in the
systems and in the incentives that the
systems create and and one of the most
obvious cases here would be climate
change because
individuals also make choices of course
about the greenhouse gases that they
emit or the again what they eat makes an
impact on their greenhouse gases that
they're responsible for as does whether
they drive a car and if they do what
sort of car to drive
um
but it's really important and shouldn't
be that difficult for governments to
change the incentives there by carbon
taxes for example on what produces
emissions so that's a that's an area
where going into politics can be a
really important career because you can
help to make governments make those
choices
um and and that's true of the other
things that I talk about at an
individual level as well governments do
give significant amounts to foreign aid
they could give more the United States
actually gives very little in terms as a
percentage of its gross national income
compared to European countries generally
and could give more and could also give
it more effectively
and of course some governments have
better laws and regulations regarding
the treatment of animals even within the
United States California has better
regulations for farm animals than most
other states in the United States
because it has uh citizen initiated
referenda and it's passed uh
propositions to give animals a bit more
room than
um they have in other states so there
are definitely things that you can do at
the policy level and that it's important
to do at the policy level
but some of these things are really
difficult to bring about change and for
example trying to increase the United
States foreign aid has been a long
struggle that so far has been quite
unsuccessful even presidents who are
sympathetic like President Obama had one
stage talked about raising U.S foreign
aid to half a percent of gross national
product which would still be only uh you
know about half of the top nations in
the world
um but completely failed to do that
um so if if that's so difficult to
achieve
um then there is something that we can
do individually and that can make a
difference so let's let's do that and
similarly in terms of what we eat it's
also very hard to get laws and
regulations to in the United States to
give animals more space to move around
as I said there are exceptions with
those states with citizens initiated
referenda because it does seem that
ordinary Americans when given that
choice will choose better conditions for
animals but because the agribusiness
Lobby is so powerful at the federal
level it's been impossible to get any
laws passed at the federal level to give
animals room to move and that's that's a
contrast with with Europe where the
entire European Union has much better
laws than the United States has so again
you know let's try to do what we can at
the individual level if enough people do
that we'll weaken the power of the
agribusiness Lobby because they won't be
selling so much and uh we'll press and
be in a better position to produce that
systemic change well in the context of
of animal rights uh
this has been a movement built upon the
shoulders of the individual like it
really has been a Grassroots movement
and you know I want to get into how this
all began with you you wrote Animal
Liberation in 1975 I want to hear how
that came into being but in in in
looking back upon you know the many
years since that book came out
it must be quite an awesome thing to see
how much progress has been made how much
energy is in this movement while also
recognizing how little has changed and
how much work remains right like how are
you thinking about the current status
quo yeah you've got that exactly right
um there has been
significant change I mentioned those
laws in the European Union sort of 27
countries that have better laws than
when I publish animal Liberation in 1975
and the United Kingdom of course which
is no longer in the European Union uh so
that's a significant change for hundreds
of millions of animals they have
definitely not idealized but they have
lives that are somewhat better than they
were in the 70s
um but on the other hand factory farming
still continues uh here in the United
States uh a lot of it goes on just as
bad as it was before in some respects
even worse because for example the
breeding of chickens for meat has
increase the speed at which they put on
weight to such a point that their
immature legs can't really bear the
weight of their bodies they're they're
very young birds when they're sent to
Market they're about six weeks old
um and they're in pain just from trying
to carry their body weight and sometimes
their legs will collapse under them and
they'll just be unable to move and then
because this is such a mass production
industry with 20 000 birds in a single
shed
um they're probably going to starve to
death or dehydrate to death because they
can't walk to food and water and
basically nobody cares about individual
chickens nobody will even see that
there's a Dan bird and pick it up and
you mainly kill it
um so you know those things have
actually got worse plus of course in
other countries in the world
particularly in East Asia where
they become more prosperous which in
itself would be a good thing but that
means they're producing a lot more meat
they're more demand for meat uh and
factory farming has hugely increased
there and again it's pretty much
unregulated yeah we we can celebrate the
growth of the vegan movement in these
kind of urban Pockets across the
developed Western world but
that's myopic in that when we canvas our
glance internationally we see the
expansion of a middle class or you know
New Wealth sectors who are going to
increase their consumption of meat at a
rate that
um
the planet really can't sustain right
and we're seeing the decimation of the
rainforest and with China you know all
of these areas that are where we're
seeing an increase in meat consumption
at an unprecedented level like this is a
global problem from not just a mass
suffering perspective but from a climate
change perspective as well
that's basically true it's interesting
that some countries have actually
started on a decline in meat consumption
Germany is one example and Sweden is
another
um so you know there's some hope that as
we become more educated more
understanding about what meat does not
only to animals but to the climate and
to the environment more generally we've
just had this meeting of
environmentalists concern to protect
species and again uh there's been a lot
of writing about how uh meat consumption
just can't continue to grow that it is
destroying the rainforest and causing
extinctions so there's some hope that
more people will realize that
but it's it's difficult and uh uh you
know to me you mentioned the pockets of
people being vegan I mean I think being
vegan is a great diet and a healthy diet
and the best diet for the for the planet
and for animals but I think we have to
work towards reduction of meat
consumption in mainstream
um because it's going to be a long time
before we get a vegan mainstream in in
most countries yeah I mean it's it there
does feel like
quite a bit of momentum behind that
right now it is mainstreaming in that so
many restaurants you can at least get
vegan options and people don't bulk or
and they're not confused when you want
to veganize an entree at a restaurant or
what have you
um but yes there is there is
so much work to be done and your
question really brings up this notion of
effective activism like how do you
sort of convince the most number of
people to change their habits to have
the greatest impact right is it is it
like throwing a bucket of blood on a on
a on a runway model you know at a
fashion show who's wearing a uh a mink
coat or is it
having a you know realistic conversation
with policy makers about a slight
reduction in harm that could actually
impact millions of people and benefit
millions of animals like how do you
think about carrying the message from a
utilitarian perspective to leverage the
greatest change
I think that as far as trying to get
people to change their diet is concerned
uh probably being cool and reasonable is
better than throwing Buckets of Blood at
people that's that's true but you know
we don't fully know and I would like to
see and this is part of what effective
altruism wants to do I would like to see
more studies about you know what is the
effect of people when
um there are protests that are more in
your face uh than others uh there's some
suggestions that it puts people off but
I don't really know that we know and for
example on issues like climate change
which seems to me to be a really urgent
issue I can fully understand uh those
Eco activists who
um through soup over Van Gogh's
sunflowers and let me say they knew it
was behind glass so they knew it wasn't
going to damage the original painting
um but you know that was a gesture to
say you know this is really something
urgent and we're still not doing what we
need to be doing about it and we have to
do better and we have to do it soon so I
I fully sympathize with that but I do
want to know what actually is going to
work and what is going to get
governments to take the relatively
simple steps that they need to take to
shift us away from uh greenhouse gas
emitting uh products both fossil fuels
and meat in particular
I feel like most people want to eat
better they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy a vibrant
plant-based meals and if you're looking
for the perfect holiday gift for a loved
one right now for a limited time we're
offering twenty dollars off meal planner
gift cards through December 15th visit
meals.rich roll.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
how have your views uh evolved since
writing this book in 1975 on this
subject matter well
um perhaps I was uh a little naive about
how easy it might have been to to change
these deeply ingrained habits and to
combat major industries because I did
think that the arguments seem to me to
be so clear
I thought that if I could just State
them clearly and rationally uh readers
would
decide that they were right they would
change what they were eating they would
talk to their friends about why it was
important to change what I was eating
and
um I hoped at least that's how you
that's how it happened for you right so
why shouldn't that happen for anybody
who's reading your book exactly that's
right yeah I mean so I didn't think
about this issue at all until I was a
graduate student at Oxford 24 years old
and I hadn't thought about it no this
was 1970 so it wasn't really discussed
you didn't meet vegetarians or certainly
not Western vegetarians you might have
met some Indian vegetarians but you
didn't meet
people who were like you who were
vegetarians
um until I uh at Oxford happened to have
lunch with a Canadian graduate student
called Richard Cashin
who uh asked whether there was meat in
the spaghetti sauce that was being
served and when he was told there was he
took a salad plate instead
um and I was surprised and asked him
what his problem was with me and he told
me that he didn't think it was right to
treat animals the way we treat them in
order to turn them into food and I said
don't they have good lives out in the
fields and he said no they're
increasingly they're crowded inside in
big dark sheds I knew nothing about that
I made it my business to find out and
then I also because I was a philosophy
student I decided to look at what
philosophers had said about this you
know why is it okay that to treat
animals in this way
um why do the bands of morality as it
seems at home just stop with our species
and I decided both that he was right on
the facts and that there wasn't an
ethical justification for disregarding
the interests of non-human animals in
the way we were doing it
so it seemed a pretty simple argument to
me and if I could be persuaded by that
and I could show the facts to other
people and and look at the ethical
arguments that that would convince other
people and it convinced some other
people that's that's the good news
um the bad news is that we are still
living in societies where the majority
of people are not only eating meat but
even buying factory farm products not
particularly looking for
um more organic or free-ranging or
certified Humane Animal products yeah I
think that that with greater education
around this issue also comes concerted
efforts to
confuse consumers right there's a lot of
green washing going on and there's a lot
of
um energy around uh you know kind of the
the grass-fed free-range animals that
make people feel better about their
animal consumption without fully
understanding the equation like this
idea that we actually need the animals
to regenerate the soil and you eating
um
your animals from these Farms is
actually part of the climate solution
and these animals live great lives and
certainly that's a better situation than
the factory farmed animals which is the
big gaping problem that needs to be
solved but I think uh it allows people
to kind of fall into uh sort of a
an acceptance or uh you know a delusion
that
um they're still not their habits aren't
are aren't really resulting in the harm
that they're actually
resulting in yeah I don't say they're
very inelegantly but I think you know
what I'm getting at I know what you're
getting it yes yeah
um but in fact it is a delusion I think
and I'm not sure maybe people are aware
of it but because if you ask people
uh if they eat meat and when they say
yes you ask them do they mostly buy
organic or certified Humane grass-fed
something like that
um the percentages that answers yes is
just wildly more than the amount that is
actually produced you know by a high
multiple so either people somehow
believe that they're buying these better
products when they're not or they're
just lying in the in the answers that
they're giving because if you look for
example at a chicken meat production the
example I gave it earlier I think it's
99.8 is Factory farmed in in the US it's
a tiny tiny percentage
um far less less than one percent so um
you know if people say they're eating
humanely produced uh chicken they are
almost certainly not yeah well if if the
reduction of suffering is the is the
rubric there is an interesting
philosophical
uh exploration to be had
uh
when it comes to the the kind of
carnivore people who call who call what
they eat like nose to tail like from a
suffering perspective if somebody's
going to take one cow and they're going
to consume the entirety of that is that
a more ethical Choice than the vegan
who's eating plants that are you know
sort of threshed in a traditional way
where lots of rodents and insects are
are being sacrificed as a result of the
harvesting of these many plants or
Gophers having to be killed Etc where in
other words like lots of different
animals are sacrificed for the
production of these plant Foods versus
the person who eats the cow who says
well this is just one sentient being
like from a philosophical ethical
perspective like how do you think about
that or
parse the difference
yes
um
so there are a couple of things to be
said about that uh one is that from a
climate point of view uh cows and and
beef is really the worst of the animal
products in terms of the quantity of
greenhouse gases because they produce
methane and methane is an extremely
potent greenhouse gas and they've had to
consume a lot of resources to get to the
point before they're killed for food
right right well I mean so if if they're
in feedlots
um or fat in the last few months in
feedlots eating grain then all of those
problems about uh the rodents that get
killed with the threshing are going to
be there because they will have eaten
far more grain than a vegan would eat
because you only get back from from
feeding grain to to cattle you get back
um somewhere between five and ten
percent of the food value of the grain
that you're putting in so if you're
eating the grains directly uh you eat
far fewer grains but if people are
saying well I'm just eating fully grass
fed beef which is again is quite a small
proportion of U.S produced beef then
you're not you're not killing the
rodents when you harvest the grain
because they're they're eating grass but
they actually produce more greenhouse
gases than the feedlots and that's
because the reason cattle put in
feedlots is they fatten up faster on
grain so if they're on grass they have
to live longer to reach the same weight
to produce the same quantity of meat for
people to eat and all the time they're
living and digesting the grass they're
producing the methane so in terms of the
impact on the climate it's really bad it
may be better from an animal welfare
point of view much better than eating
chicken for example both because they're
outside and have better lives and also
because you're talking about one animal
with a lot of meat whereas chickens you
people eat it who eat chickens are
eating a lot of chickens over their
lifetime
but but in terms of greenhouse gases
it's actually us
beyond that there isn't enough land to
support the production of of cattle in
that manner anyway to meet Global demand
for me well that's right so it's not a
scalable sustainable solution no and and
some of it and the demand for beef is
causing rainforest to be cleared causing
the Amazon to be cleared for for grazing
land for example or even to grow more
soybeans in Brazil which also uh about
70 of the soybean crop gets uh fed to
cattle
um and I think something over 20 goes to
biofuels
um and you know people say oh I don't
eat tofu because soybeans are bad but
actually it's you know about seven
percent of the whole soybean crop is
actually eaten directly by humans either
as beans or as as tofu
um and the great majority is getting
funneled through cattle and again we
lose most of the food value of the
soybeans when we do that right
um back to the earlier question about
how your your ideas have evolved since
1975 are there other
other thing like if you so you are going
you're you're reprising this book right
you're coming out a new edition of it so
I suspect
there are uh you know things that you
want to change or I don't know how much
you can talk about that specifically but
maybe generally uh you know how your
thinking has changed and evolved in in
the many interceding years yeah that's
right I'm producing you know what's
effectively a new book that's been
called animal Liberation now
um which has maintained the key ethical
ideas
um completely updates the relevant facts
and looks at uh progress that we've made
um and that we've not made from a more
Global Perspective so it has a lot of
new things in it that weren't in the
original Edition
um my thinking has developed in in
various respects
um I suppose some of the things that I'm
more concerned with now are questions
about wild animals about should we be
concerned about uh the suffering of wild
animals and my what might we do with
that
um I'm also interested in the
development of alternatives to to meet
um I see that as a positive sign both
plant-based meats and
um the development of cellular meat so
you know meat that is actually produced
from animal cells but does not require
any uh living animal organism and
therefore is again fallow on greenhouse
gas emissions maybe has about three
percent of the greenhouse gas emissions
of meat from animals and doesn't involve
the animal suffering of course because
there's no conscious animal there so if
we could do that and if we could
um
produce it in a economically competitive
price with the meat that is being sold
from animals uh that might be another
way of breaking this uh deadlock of
trying to get people to move away from
uh eating animal products that are so
bad for animals and for the environment
well all indications is that we're we
are headed in that direction it may take
a little bit more
time because this is an expensive
um problem to solve right figuring out
how to culture
these cells and create these you know
quote unquote meat products they're able
to do it they've established that it can
be done but doing it economically so
it's
um on par with what it would cost to go
to McDonald's or what have you there's
still a lot of work to be done right yes
that's right and you can actually buy uh
cellular Chicken in Singapore now it's
like it's for sale there but
um it's yes it's expensive and uh I
think the problem is they need to scale
up and there's some questions about
building these huge bioreactors in which
the process occurs can that be done
um will there be problems with things
going astray we really don't know but
but there's quite a lot of capital being
invested in it a lot of capital yeah and
but also the question of just you know
consumer acclimation to it there is that
the sort of getting over that icky
factor of like what is this and where
does it come from and
you know having uh you know consumers uh
acclimate to the idea of of this new
food that's true although
um consumers seem to think that the meat
that they're buying is somehow natural
and and that's obviously transformed
tremendously in the last 50 years yeah
you know the animals are bred
differently as I was saying I mean the
the the chickens
can't really live to maturity mostly
because they're they're bred to eat so
fast and put on weight so fast that a
lot of them will just you know collapse
and die
um if they were kept to to older Birds
um in fact it's so it's so bad that uh
with the breeding birds because the
parents of course have to have the same
genes as the one we eat they have to be
starved basically because if you've fed
them as much as they want to eat they
would not be able to to survive to breed
or they might not physically be able to
breed because they would be too obese to
actually do that so um so they tend to
be fed every second day which means that
they're desperately hungry all the time
uh and then of course the antibiotics
are used because they're under under
stress so a lot of antibiotics that are
losing their efficacy because we're
feeding them routinely to farm animals
uh so yeah that this this is not a
natural product either but somehow
people have been persuaded to continue
to eat it think that think of it as good
uh so no doubt there will be some some
let's say uh need to show consumers that
this cellular meat when it happens is
essentially still meat and is actually a
safer and purer product than what
they're getting from factory farms have
you tried it no I've not had the
opportunity to try it yet um I would
certainly do so if I find myself in
Singapore yeah I will go and do that
right how do you think about uh
philanthropy in in the Animal Welfare
space uh it seems like there's a lot of
um
uh room sort of improvement to be had in
terms of like how to leverage the dollar
for the most good when we look at the
big problems versus where people's kind
of hearts and emotions absolutely yeah
in fact I show my students a slide uh of
that which which has two boxes one box
shows where the greatest amount of
animal suffering is and and animals
being killed and it's overwhelmingly
farmed animals
um and so it's like a big square of one
color for farmed animals and then Dan in
in the bottom corner there's a tiny
little square that shows uh the other
things like laboratory animals it's
pretty small too although it's probably
around 100 million animals in the United
States each year
um there's things like Furs and then
there's dogs and cats which is just a
tiny Mac you can hardly see on on my
slide and then then the adjacent box
shows where the dollars are going and
there it's it's the dogs and cats the
animal shelters that is the dominant
thing and uh farmed animal are quite
small and laboratory animals are quite
small wild animals do rank larger there
so uh yeah there's this complete
disconnect between where the dollars go
and where they're needed we're starting
to get a little more money going through
effective altruism actually mostly
um through foundations like um open
philanthropy which is funded by Dustin
Moskowitz and Carrie tuna which is
directing more money to uh oppose
factory farming but um but what's going
coming from the general public is really
not going to where the big animal
suffering problems are it's going to
where people's emotions are
um and you know it's not that effective
altruism doesn't want people to have
emotions it's just that they want people
to feel the emotions and then think you
know yes I care about dogs and cats but
I also care about animals in general I
don't want you know pigs or cows or
chickens to suffer I don't want wild
animals to suffer I don't want even rats
and mice to suffer in laboratory
experiments
um and so if I care about animals I
should be thinking about giving to where
it will help the big problems and not
the relatively small problems that's
what we need to get people to think
about sure but isn't there a place for
that emotional impulse like if you think
about
so for example in the in the Animal
Welfare space like a lot of people
donate towards these shelters right like
they they rescue farmed animals they
create a beautiful place for them to
live out their lives and those places
and people feel good about supporting
those places for obvious reasons but
those places also serve as sort of
museums for people to visit which gets
you know perhaps other people who have
no connection to this movement or these
ideas this is their Inception point for
even learning about this
an emotional connection to the reality
of the problem that might in turn
motivate them to give or get involved in
the solution and maybe that solution is
an effective altruism solution or maybe
it's something else but I can't help but
ask you like where is the emotional
piece like there has to be some
importance and resonance for it on some
level
yeah definitely I think that uh emotion
is important and with the animal
sanctuaries that you mentioned I think
they do get people to see found animals
as individuals and that's important
um they get them to see that some of
them can actually grow old even which of
course farmed animals never do it's the
rescued ones that might
um and those sanctuaries work and many
of them do and I think they all should
um as places of Education that get
people to see animals differently and
encourage them to do more for
farmed animals in general
so I think that's fine
um and I think in terms of global
poverty too it's important emotion plays
a role and it's important to tell the
stories of individuals of those children
whose lives have been saved by a
treatment that was made available
through an organization that had
community health workers going around
and helping
um or you know restoring people's sight
is something where you can really see
the emotion and
um the life you can save the
organization that I founded that
recommends effective Charities
recommends a couple that do restore
sight in uh
countries where otherwise people with
quite simple conditions like cataracts
would never be able to see again and you
can see videos online of how somebody's
you know when the bandages are removed
after an operation was performed and the
eyes are recovered and you see a woman
who sees her child for the first time
that she's ever seen that two-year-old
child and say and that's a wonderful
heartwarming experience and I hope it
will encourage people to think yes this
is really a good thing to be doing this
is such an important work to support
right yeah that's really beautiful uh
the the counter side of that like as a
thought experiment as somebody who's
primary driver is a reduction of
suffering if you think about the
eradication of of global poverty if
you're raising the kind of
um
uh life experience and and income of
people who have grown up in poverty
um they then become do they not then
what what happens if those people then
end up increasing their meat consumption
and that drives uh you know cattle
producers to clear more rainforest to
produce that cattle like when you look
at the macro benefit versus harm
calculus from a philosophical point of
view like how do you make sense of that
yeah
that's that's a tough problem I've
grappled with uh trying to think about
that and trying to think about my
anti-poverty work on how does it connect
with my concern for animals but I
suppose what I say and you may think
that this is a rationalization is that
if we're ever to solve this problem
we're not going to solve it by keeping
people in poverty because when people
are in poverty they will do whatever
they have to do sure to survive and if
that includes for example uh killing
wild animals in the forest and I uh
including even chimpanzees in some
places and uh perhaps leading to the
extinction of species in the forest uh
they're going to do that so I think we
have to try to get people out of poverty
and hope that when they have more
choices when they are out of poverty
they will eventually come to see that
um eating more meat is is not the right
thing to do and we will have
alternatives for them that they can live
good and healthy lives without eating
more meat or perhaps without eating any
meat and so that we'll get to the point
where I'm hoping we all get to where we
have expanded Our concern for all
animals for all sentient beings and are
not just thinking about human beings so
you know as you say you may you may
think that that's
no it's just interesting to think about
like I'm not wed to any answer or any I
I think just grappling with that idea
demonstrates how difficult problem
solving is in the real world if you're
if you're if your goal really is like
how do we best eradicate suffering it's
complicated it's nuanced and it's in the
gray I think there's you know another
way of of exploring that is is the Twist
on your famous thought experiment of the
girl in the in the pond right so first
of all for people who don't know you
know maybe explain what that thought
experiment is sure okay so in an article
I wrote a long time ago I asked my
readers to imagine that they're walking
past uh upon let's say an ornamental
pond in a park and let's say they know
well that the pond is quite shallow
um and as they walk past it they notice
that there's something struggling in the
water and when they look more closely
turns out it's a very small child child
too small to stand up even in this
shallow pond
so you know the first thing you would
think about is whose Child is This who's
looking after this child but when you
look around you don't know why but
there's nobody else there you're the
only adult inside
so your second thought I hope is Gee
this child seems to be drowning I better
jump into the pond and save the child
but then maybe you have a third and not
so Noble thought and that is I'm wearing
my best clothes today because I was
going somewhere special and they're
going to get ruined if I save the child
by jumping into the pond
so
what if I just forget that I ever saw
the child and go on my way
um would that be the wrong thing to do
and I hope that all your listeners are
now saying of course that would be the
wrong thing to do how could you compare
the value of a child's life with uh
you know ruining your shoes or your
clothes
so the point of the example is to say
yes that is the right reaction that you
should have and it would be the wrong
thing to do but it's not only in these
uh you know unlikely circumstances where
you have to ruin your clothes to save a
child in a pond
it's happening to us all the time that
for the cost of replacing those clothes
donated to a effective charity
we could save or certainly contribute
towards saving the life of a child in a
low-income country perhaps by donating
to the against malaria Foundation which
will distribute bed nets to protect
children against malaria or perhaps by
Distributing other medicines to prevent
children dying of diarrhea which is
another significant cause of deaths in
in low-income countries and the point
being that the physical location of the
suffering child should not have an
impact on the decision to give or not
give that's right I think if you reflect
on it and you ask yourself does the fact
that the child is physically close to me
really make a moral difference to how
important it is to help that child to
save that child's life I think most of
us would say no that's not the important
thing sure proximity being irrelevant
and then there's all kinds of other
threads that can be pulled on this does
temporality matter like does the fact
that this person is living at the same
time like we can we can predict that in
the future that will there will be
people in this circumstance right and
the fact that they don't live yet uh
should that be
a a factor in our decision to think
about how much of our income we're going
to give over to
increase the well-being of the world
I think that if there are people who are
going to be living in the future and
they are going to be either suffering or
dying prematurely in ways we could
prevent uh the fact that it's in the
future doesn't in itself matter uh if
we're uncertain as to whether we could
do anything to prevent their suffering
that of course makes a difference we
have to Discount the good of what we're
trying to achieve by the odds against us
actually managing to achieve it so yes
do act where good consequences are more
certain but not just the future
um the Oxford philosopher Derek parfitt
had an example uh about leaving Broken
Glass somewhere in the forest and let's
say it'll take a while nobody's going to
tread on it in coming years but at some
point a child maybe not yet born will
walk along that path and cut their feet
on it does that mean that it didn't
matter because they aren't born at the
time that you left a broken glass in the
path no it doesn't really matter um the
pain of the child is the same and it's
you know it's just the same it's just as
it's just as significant
um if you can predict that it is very
likely to happen and that opens the door
to a whole discussion around
long-termism which is which is you know
very related to it's an extension of of
your work in many ways
yes that's true um there's there's one
difference with the really long-termest
predictions if you're wanting to
intervene not uh in a way that's going
to make a difference to somebody living
in 20 50 or 100 years but in many
centuries or many Millennia or even
millions of years then firstly there is
a quite different uncertainty factor
that comes in in terms of how do we
really know that what we're doing now
will make a difference
but there's also the fact that
um when long-termers try to prevent
Extinction and then they say
there could be these vast numbers of
human beings Living Rich and fulfilling
lives as long as we don't do something
that causes our species to become
extinct let's say this Century or the
next couple of centuries
um then you do have to think about well
if we did something that
meant that we became extinct these
people wouldn't exist at all so it
wouldn't be like a child cutting their
foot and getting hurt it would be like
there just would be
nobody alive on the planet maybe there
would be no sentient beings in this part
of the Universe
um and some philosophers think that
that's different that
we don't have an obligation to ensure
that future people exist uh rather we
have an obligation to say that if people
exist in future we don't do anything
that will harm them hmm
I want to get into life extension uh and
the anti-aging stuff because I feel like
that's the next logical step from what
you just shared but to put a pin on that
for now and circle back to the to the
the girl drowning in the pond the
original question being
um
you know coming out of this idea of of
of of suffering reduction if you save
that girl which we all agree is the
right thing to do if you're passing by
uh
it can be presumed that that individual
will go on to live some number of years
and will consume will consume many
things including probably animal
products which has its own Downstream
implications in terms of harm and uh you
know it's a resource allocation Etc so
it's back to that I think there was
actually an article in your your Journal
about this right like the Journal of
controversial ideas like that's right
let's explore this idea like if you're
saving this individual altruistically
there's also harm that is incident to
that
to that act right that's right yeah it
was an article written by somebody with
the name Michael plant which is his real
name oh it's his real name yeah
articles with pseudonyms that's right
yeah yeah if anyone wants to read it by
the way as you mentioned the Journal of
controversial ideas it's uh Open Access
just Google yeah Journal of
controversial ideas uh you'll get to it
yeah it's it's it's a it's a thoughtful
article
um and it does raise that problem
um about the the meat eaters whose lives
we're saving uh and ask whether we
should be doing that
um
I'm
I'm somewhat unsure I mean I've I've
actually talked to Michael plant about
this um and uh he's he's quite
persuasive but uh at the moment I'm
going to say let's try and save those
lives and hope that we can
persuade people and move people towards
a a lifestyle in which we're not causing
so much suffering to animals right I
think in order to really flesh that out
you have to
think about speciesism this sense that
you know we we create a rank hierarchy
uh amongst the animal kingdom based upon
people's cognitive abilities and their
level of sentience right which is not
necessarily correlated to their ability
to suffer But to answer that question
about harm reduction
do you not have to place a value you
know a greater value on one life over
another right from a species perspective
so I wouldn't do that on a species basis
that is I wouldn't say that being a
member of the species Homo Sapien
automatically means that your life is
more valuable than a member of any other
species
I would say that beings who have
cognitive capacities that enable them to
think about their lives and think about
the lives of others whom they love and
care for in ways that are different and
perhaps more profound and more lasting
than other beings
that it's
a greater tragedy when they die
prematurely than when those other beings
die prematurely so I don't think of
the lives of all sentient beings as
being of equal value
um I do think of their suffering as
being equally important when we're
talking about similar kinds and similar
quantities of suffering but uh not
the preservation of their lives yeah
they're uncomfortable
uh idea as a parent when I think about
the the pond and the girl uh is is this
idea of of like we we all sort of
intuitively feel like we can
prefer the well-being of our children
over other children and that is sort of
accepted like of course I'm going to
make sure that I'm providing for my
children uh even though they live in a
you know much better circumstances than
most children in the world
um
but from a harm reduction perspective
would it not be better for me to
allocate my resources more
democratically so that uh you know my
kids are sort of not getting any more
than all these other children who need
more I think it would be better from a
purely impartial perspective if we could
do that but you know we are mammals
we're not going to do that no we're not
gonna I agree we're not going to do it
you're a parent you didn't do that right
and you're the you're the Godfather of
all of this okay so uh what I want to
say about this is that it would be from
this impartial perspective better if I
were to do that but um I don't think we
should blame ourselves for not doing it
because I think we should recognize that
that's something that is
basically
um imprinted in a genes that we are
going to care for our children more than
the children of strangers that's what
our ancestors did for millions of years
and that's why we are here because if
they hadn't then they wouldn't have
survived or they wouldn't have their
children wouldn't have survived
so I think we have to be somewhat
indulgent to ourselves in that not as
indulgent as many people are I don't
think we should be doing you know
everything imaginable for our children I
think the automatic assumption that you
leave all your wealth to your children
is not something that is Justified
especially if they are already quite
comfortably off and we are living in a
world where there's so much uh extreme
poverty and so much need but
um we should we should try to try to do
better we should try to get to more
equitable distribution and we should try
to encourage others to do that uh but as
I say you know we're not Saints we we
um we haven't evolved to be Saints with
very very rare exceptions and we
shouldn't beat ourselves up because
we're not right
there's a lot of uh science and money
and energy right now going into the uh
extension of lifespan like this
anti-aging movement that's a foot uh and
there are plenty of people hard at work
on solving the problem of Aging as if it
is a disease with prospects of really
substantially extending lifespan to 150
years and maybe even Beyond with certain
scientific breakthroughs on the horizon
and like any technology that the human
race Pioneers there is from my
perspective this sense of like
inevitability like we're not going to
stop or slow down and think about the
implications of this we're held bent on
just achieving it for the sake of
achievement because it's a mountain yet
to be climbed and I feel like there's an
important philosophical conversation
that we need to have about the
implications of what the world might be
like if suddenly people could live to
300 or Beyond from from a wealth
distribution perspective from a rights
perspective and from like a risk
calculus perspective like what would it
mean if you could live 300 years what is
your imprint or your responsibility like
your your carbon footprint and your
responsibility to the planet to Future
Generations how do you think about you
know how many children you're going to
have if you're going to live that long
things like this is this anything that
you've spent any time thinking about I
have spent some time thinking about it I
actually published an article on
lifespan extension back in the 1980s
when we were not that close to making
breakthroughs but but people did think
even then that we might not be very far
away and uh although as you say I I
agree that it's going to come at some
point I'm not convinced it's going to
come really soon sure it may be harder
than people think but uh yes it
certainly raises some serious ethical
issues uh and there could be some good
sides to it for example you talked about
uh views about risk we might be less
inclined to take risks if we have the
prospect of living for hundreds of years
we might be less ready to fight in war
for example we might not see Wars of the
kind we have now in Ukraine to the same
extent because people think you know I
want to live a long time I don't want to
die in my 20s when I could live another
200 years and also when you think about
things like climate change
um what would how would that affect our
views now we're saying well we need to
do this for our children and
grandchildren at least people of my
generation are saying that
um if I we were going to be living 300
years we would think hey we're going to
be living in this world with a vastly
different and less stable climate so we
better stop what we're doing right now
so that could be a good consequence but
there's a real danger there if you
simply
expand lives for those who can afford it
um and you don't do anything to reduce
population growth of course then then
the world will become even more
populated than it is now and that's a
serious problem so uh would that slow
down would that stop
um you'd have to hope so because
otherwise uh we're definitely going to
be over capacity even more than we are
already perhaps now it's hard to imagine
that if and when those breakthroughs
occur that uh they will be reserved for
the wealthy like it's not going to be a
democratic thing right so it's just
going to drive
of Greater wedge in between the halves
and the haves-nots
yes that's certainly going to be what
will happen initially
um it might be one of those procedures
that if you find in fact that you can
find inexpensive ways of doing it that
it will spread but initially yeah we're
going to get the wealthy people living
longer it's just the same thing with
with Gene editing I think we're going to
get them being able to produce children
who have enhanced capacities to earn
well and to be useful in various ways
and so you will get wealthy people who
are breeding children who are more
significantly different genetically from
low-income people than than they are now
and you'll actually get a sort of
genetically fixed caste Society uh
occurring so I think these are these are
serious problems for uh technologies
that are that are in the pipeline right
the other the other primary technology
uh being the pioneering of new forms of
Consciousness through artificial
intelligence it's right there's a lot of
discussion around what constitutes
sentience what is consciousness Etc and
we're seeing in real time like these
breakthroughs with you know chat GPT and
things like this where artificial
intelligence is mimicking
behavior in a way that is sort of
helping us to realize like we're kind of
on the precipice of something new here
and what does this mean for the future
of humanity and how should we think
about the ethics surrounding these
developments I think mimicking is the
right word though at present we do have
these uh chat things that that look as
if you're having a conversation with a
person who is conscious and thinking but
uh when you understand how it's actually
working I think you realize that that's
not the case but at what point like if
these things become self-learning right
the the time frame then becomes very
compressed in terms of their evolution
and development and at some point when
they become indistinguishable from human
behavior what is the Tipping Point or
the kind of Rubicon
uh where we can qualify it as sentient
or conscious like for you where what
does that line look like like what would
have to I think the difficulty is in
working out when one of these uh
uh super intelligent artificial general
intelligence actually becomes conscious
because
um if in fact it's very good at
mimicking our Behavior
and if it's also uh essentially a black
box that is we don't really understand
how it's doing what it's doing and there
is AI where we can't really say why it's
making the judgments that it's making
then it's going to be hard to know hard
to distinguish uh
conscious processing from Simply
very rapid mechanical processing and
learning and it'll be it will take an
effort to understand how it's working
and why it's doing what it is but I
think that that is that is the clue we
need to try to understand what's going
on and if we're simply saying well we
trained it on vast quantities of text
and it absorbed that and then we train
it as to how to give the right answers
and it's just doing that then I think
it's clear that it's it's not a
conscious being right but on some level
already we're in a situation where we
don't quite know how it's coming up with
the right answer like we know it's
self-reinforcing on some level but
already the the computer scientists like
the this sort of process by which it's
operating has already begun to elude the
creators of the technology yes so that's
sort of frightening it is right it's
funny in a variety of ways yes and at
what point does it become unethical to
flick the switch and turn it off so to
speak
because we have given birth to a new
form of life and Consciousness that
deserves its own you know respect on
some level even as as it's going about
destroying us right and if we simply ask
it and say you know is it okay for me to
pick the switch and turn you off right
um and it probably you know we'll take
this as oh does that mean you're killing
me and then you know I know what people
say about being killed so so it comes
out with the answer that a sure a person
would give if you said I'm going to kill
you
um that's not going to be the dystopian
World in which we're headed Peter how
how are we gonna make sense of this how
are we going to survive this impending
apocalypse
so I'm not convinced that we're that
close to this particular apocalypse yet
right I think we have lots of problems
I'd much rather focus on climate change
extreme poverty getting rid of factory
farming
um I think the robot apocalypse is still
some distance yeah ahead of us and I
don't know that we yet have a good
enough handle as to how it's going to
happen so I would rather wait and see
yeah well I mean I think it's good to be
thinking about these things and I know
you like there are other Oxford
philosophers who are on this yeah
Bostrom and Toby ORD right have written
written about this extensively and it's
sexy and it's fun you know to it feels
very you know Terminator world to like
think about these problems and and
certainly at some point perhaps this
these are very real things that we need
to Grapple with but what's interesting
to me about it is the obsession with
with trying to understand the ethics
around emergent like robotic
Consciousness
um beliees the fact that currently there
are billions of animals that were
sacrificing
constantly for our food system and we
don't really think about their like the
the ethics of their conscious awareness
and suffering yeah like this big problem
is right underneath our foot and we're
worrying about this problem that's
coming down the line and we should be
there's value in that of course yeah but
we already have a very real circumstance
right here that we kind of walk around
with blinders on around yes that's right
I actually co-authored an article with a
Hong Kong researcher called sayiphai who
um looked and he he looked at a whole
lot of courses on AI ethics and a whole
lot of AI ethics statements and lots of
them take very seriously this still
hypothetical question of what would be
the moral status of conscious AI
but pretty much none of them actually
take seriously the effect of the the
present impact that AI is having on
sentient beings non-human sentient
beings on on animals they of course deal
with impact of AI on humans but
um we show in the article that AI is
already having a major impact on
non-human animals for example in some
countries it's being used to run factory
farms not really in the United States
but that's happening in China that's
happening in in Europe to some extent
just automated like sort of automated
factory farms where algorithms are
dictating feeding schedules and things
like that that's right yes they look
that's right and they they are sensors
that are observing animal behavior and
adjusting the the what is done to the
Animals by how they're behaving
um possibly detecting diseases early
which could be a good thing but they're
also going to enable animals to be even
more crowded
um because of the AI will actually be
geared to where is it most profitable
what's the point at which it's a very
it's a very rudimentary Matrix where
this living being is exists for the
purpose of resource extraction right yes
a battery that's right exactly if a
resource extraction and and not treated
as a thing as as an end in itself as a
sentient being with a moral status that
is different from from that of a of a
thing of a product yeah that's that's
wild I mean do you
when you cast your gaze into the future
are you an optimistic person or you know
how do you how do you how is all this
gonna how is all this playing out
I've always been optimistic
um I wrote a book back in the 80s called
the expanding Circle in which I talked
about the way in which throughout human
history we have pushed the boundaries of
our moral sphere outwards from from the
tribe to larger groups to National
groups
um to racial or ethnic groups and
finally in the 20th century to
recognizing with the universal
Declaration of Human Rights that all
human beings have certain basic rights
and I looked forward to pushing that
beyond the boundaries of our species to
non-human animals and there are some
signs of that happening
but over the last 20 years uh there have
been backward steps as well uh in terms
of
um both in terms of
human relations and the idea that we
have a pretty naked war of aggression
going on right now with Russia's
invasion of Ukraine and people dying and
being killed
is something that makes it hard to be
optimistic about our future but also in
terms of the treatment of animals we
haven't continued to push outwards in
the way that I'd hoped and finally
climate change is still you know the
huge problem that we have not done
enough about and if we don't solve that
then things are going to go backwards
and we will be in Greater need and no
doubt we'll have climate Wars because of
uh huge numbers of refugees wanting to
leave places where they can no longer
live and grow their own food
so
um I'm
more agnostic now about whether I think
the future is going to be positive yeah
the expanding circles concept was
another thing that you talked about with
Ryan holiday he was analogizing it I
think it was Heracles who had written
about it that's right yeah that's right
yes I didn't even really know that uh
which is pretty cool yeah you tapped
into the you know greater Consciousness
to explore that idea but I think you
know when you think about or sort of the
erosion of your optimism
um to me it just feels like human beings
are not very well wired for uh
for decision making around long-term
consequences right like we're acting in
our self-interest it's very difficult
for us to think about future generations
and when you see our inability to
take appropriate action with respect to
climate change there's a feeling of of
like
like we're we're somehow Were Somehow
neutered like whether there's not enough
political capital or we can't Marshal
our incentive structure to you know
create better decision making around
this it's easy to not be optimistic
about how we're going to solve this
problem because there's so much in disha
of us not taking action where we should
yeah and part of the problem I think is
that we do not have strong Global
organizations and and we really need
that um I also wrote a book uh called
One World
um was published just after 9 11. and uh
in that
I was looking towards the strengthening
of global institutions because I argued
that we need them to deal with climate
change we we just have one atmosphere
you can't you can't govern climate
change with Sovereign Nations because
the greenhouse gases that we emit uh
across the United States obviously
spread everywhere
um also I thought that we needed uh a
World Trading organization that was more
geared towards helping people in extreme
poverty we liked that I wanted to have
stronger international legal system so
that crimes against humanity would be
punished everywhere
um
and I wanted us to do more about global
poverty
um and if you look at those areas we
certainly haven't got the strong
institutions to govern uh climate change
uh the move towards international law
that seemed reasonably promising then
with the setting up of the international
criminal court has had very limited
success
um and you know if you look at the war
crimes being committed by Russia in
Ukraine it's hard to see how the people
responsible are ever going to be brought
to Justice there the World Trade
Organization basically stalled around
the time the book came out and hasn't
been able to make progress towards
better trading regimes for countries
that are low income and disadvantaged by
present systems so uh you know perhaps
we've made some progress in in terms of
global poverty that has been reduced
over that 20-year period quite
dramatically but that's really the one
right spot in in this picture uh and
that's why it's hard to see uh that
positive future
Global cooperation seems
very elusive
it's that definitely we've gone back
with uh with the conflict between Russia
and the West now
um and China as well uh not being part
of global trading order the Hope was
that if they realize that they need to
trade and the trade is helping them
helping their economy and helping to
lift hundreds of millions of Chinese out
of poverty that uh then they would be a
participant
um in this and we would have a
multi-polar world uh well I suppose it's
uh it's multi-polar but uh there's more
confrontation than yeah there was 20
years ago yeah and these sort of global
Gatherings are you know often about
political expediency you know there's
there's a lot of uh words being said but
in terms of like real world action with
the intended positive effect
that doesn't seem to occur with anything
certainly not in the way that it needs
to occur to solve the problems but to
hearken that that that stoic tradition
of of the intersection of philosophy and
politics
you know if there were at least in
National politics a seat you know in the
white house for like the philosopher in
Chief I'm sure lots of people have
called upon you for your input and
advice on various issues but if that was
actually like a cabinet position
like you're in a parallel universe and
you're sitting there in the situation
room or whatever in the Oval Office what
have you like what is the guidance or
the counsel that you could give like
the president or our government to help
us start to make better decisions about
these problems
I would say that the United States has
to lead and it has to be prepared to
lead and ways that are clearly genuine
and Bonafide and saying look we will do
these things we will start doing them we
will do what is our fair share on things
like climate change and extreme poverty
uh and that's doing a lot more than
we're doing now on either of those
issues
um and we want you to join in and uh
let's let's be open and transparent
about what we're all doing so that we
can see who's doing their fair share and
uh you know I hope if if we make that
gesture
um you'll match it and do the same and
we'll start to build trust and
cooperation in the things that need to
be done and that can only be done if all
the major Global players participate
yeah and from a from uh an economic
perspective
you know so much of your work and your
focus is on giving and how to
effectively give but how do you think
about
uh other economic modalities like the
notion of conscious capitalism or you
know Venture Capital that is kind of
um impact oriented like I'm thinking of
do you know Jacqueline novograts and
Acumen and the work that she's doing to
eradicate poverty and kind of you know
like there are other ways Beyond just
the traditional notion of of giving to
ngos and and non-profits like how do
those operate in your thinking
absolutely I think we need to try them
all and see what works
um social Enterprises that yeah do
produce a return that are for-profit
organizations but concerned to have a
social impact
um are things worth doing um I've
actually made a small investment in a
organization that is building low-income
housing in Kenya on a for-profit basis
but um
the people there who I know some of who
are genuine people who've worked in Aid
see an opportunity here to fill the gap
between the the slums that exist in
places like Nairobi and the housing that
the wealthy can afford
so I did this because I want to see that
it works I want to have an interest in
it and be able to follow it and I have
you know no objection in fact you know
I'm all in favor of people trying new
ideas uh I think it's relatively new to
see what what works and what is going to
spread and multiply but I hope some of
these things will because they certainly
have the potential to do good
who else is is leading the way here like
when you think of people who are really
uh
um doing the right thing making a real
positive change and doing it in
innovative ways
well I think some of the um some of the
foundations that have been set up uh to
do good things like
um I already mentioned Dustin Moskowitz
and and Carrie tuna who's good Ventures
Foundation
um set up open philanthropy
and uh supporting givewell too and those
are both organizations that are trying
to assess what's the best thing you can
do to have a positive impact on the
world uh give well like the life you can
save is concerned with global poverty
and with assessing which are the most
effective charities in the field of
global poverty whereas open philanthropy
is much broader and is looking at a
whole range of different areas and
trying to assess where you can make that
impact so I think I think those are
really important things to do because we
need to have that knowledge and then we
can follow through
um I think Bill Gates has been a Pioneer
too I should say in setting up the Gates
Foundation Bill and Melinda Gates I
should say and with support from Warren
Buffett
um they're also uh doing a lot of good
things uh saving a lot of lives
improving the quality of many lives so I
think uh you know they they deserve
recognition and and Applause for having
made that contribution and also
incidentally for trying to persuade
other billionaires to do the same
through the giving pledge yeah is there
a different standard for the billionaire
class
uh so obviously if you have that much
you ought to be giving a lot more right
uh yes but is there so for example uh
you know is it okay for the billionaire
to be pursuing space travel when those
resources could go towards eradicating
poverty like how do you think about the
switching you know like that that the
focus of that resource allocation
decision making process if you think if
you're thinking about about the sort of
boosting themselves into space for uh
should they be purchasing Twitter or
should they be you know
I I wish uh Elon Musk had stayed with um
developing better batteries so that we
can all be driving electric vehicles
sooner um that seems to me to be his
major contribution so far
um I I acknowledge that you know behind
his idea of colonizing Mars is this idea
of reducing the risk of Extinction right
that if we had a self-sustaining human
Colony on Mars and let's say there was a
nuclear war on this planet that wiped
everybody out here well
um you would still have our species and
maybe in a few hundred years they could
come back to a less radioactive Earth
and re-establish things here or explore
other planets elsewhere so it's not that
it's not that it's you know completely
self-indulgent to try to develop
colonies on Mars but uh I do think that
there are more
urgent issues that we could deal with
here first right well we can leave that
with that okay on that subject
um and and let it be known that that you
do put your money where your mouth is
you recently were the recipient of this
one million dollar prize honoring you
for your work and philosophy and
Humanities and that that prize was
quickly dispatched to uh the life you
can save your organization and then to
all I think 50 got
spread out to Charities that that
organization has sort of vetted and
supported yes and then the other half
went to animal rights and yeah basically
and anti-factory farming uh privilege
pro-vegan
um organizations particularly those
working in uh outside the Western
countries to try to develop those ideas
there right and so I'm just I'm
interested in the kind of actual
emotional experience of receiving a
million dollars and I mean does it what
is that like does it hit your bank
account and then you have to like send
it back out or can you I mean obviously
it's sort of theoretical right because
you're not you're just okay it's going
to pass through you to these other
things but it is kind of a rare
experience to be like wow there's a
million like they're giving me a million
dollars like is there was there ever a
moment where you're like
I need to give all of it
so I you have kids you have grandkids
yeah yeah you know look but this is who
you are right so I'm just it is walk me
through it it is who I am and also I've
been a Princeton Professor for more than
20 years on a comfortable salary so I'm
good I don't really feel that I need not
well I definitely didn't need it and I
don't even think that it would have made
a big difference to my happiness you
know I'm not the kind of person who
wants to dine out at uh you know 300
restaurants and drink Fine Wines I don't
need to when I travel I don't want to
live in luxury resorts actually they
occasionally get put up in these places
by conferences and so on and they they
just make me feel a bit uncomfortable
yeah um so I really have uh enough for
the kinds of things that I want
um and there is a fulfillment and
satisfaction in saying wow I have the
opportunity to help all of these
organizations to an extent that I didn't
really have before and to see what
they're doing with the money that I'm
giving and to know that it's helped a
lot of people and I hope has reduced
animal suffering as well it's been part
of that movement helped people who are
very dedicated working for these
important causes so I think I probably
got more fulfillment and satisfaction
through giving it away than I would have
got on trying to think how to spend it
on myself yeah sure I mean I think
that's a really important piece because
we've deluded ourselves into believing
that this that this you know wealth uh
will be the thing that makes us happy
but all that evidence suggests and
establishes that Beyond a certain
threshold point it doesn't do that at
all and in fact it is in the giving that
we that we are kind of
um engendered with this sense of
fulfillment which is really what we're
all kind of after right so far far be it
from being this you know
self-flagellating Pursuit it's actually
self-serving in that regard that's right
yeah um while you're also alleviating
suffering and doing all this good in the
world yeah so Charlie Bressler who's the
person who with whom I really co-founded
the life you can save
um was before he read the book that I
wrote the life you can save
um president of uh uh men's clothing
retail chain in the United States so he
had earned quite a lot of money
um but he says that uh by co-founding
the life you can save the first life
that he saved was his own because he got
so much more satisfaction and
fulfillment together with his wife from
UM helping to establish the organization
and and he became the CEO of it on
negative income because it didn't take
any salary and he actually donated to it
so um he found that really fulfilling
and uh and I agree
um you know if you
if if you pursue the materialist dream
dreaming in inverted commas
um it it doesn't fulfill you
um you give yourself a purpose and then
the purpose is to get more and more
money
um and for what uh whereas if you use
that for the purposes of saying I can do
something to help others and that's a
really lasting and important value uh
you're going to benefit yourself as well
as others right
um
that's really beautiful and uh
and I think for people who who are
listening to this who are now curious
about what that might look like for
their own lives
um they can go to uh your website for
the life you can save and there they can
sort of get a sense of some of these uh
kind of vetted uh Charities that are
doing good in the world right like
you've done the work to say we we know
these ones are the best bang for your
buck in terms of suffering reduction
that's right you can go to the life you
can save dot org and you can look at the
Charities that we recommend and click on
get more details on each one you can
also download the book uh absolutely
free as in right book uh or as an audio
book and I'm delighted that the
audiobook different chapters were read
by different people
um my friend Paul Simon the
singer-songwriter uh read one uh um yes
you read one yeah Stephen Fry I Stephen
Fry that's right so we have a yeah we
have a series of voices and and
different accents in English we had
Shabana azmi who's an Indian actress
reading it in her and we have uh Winnie
Alma who's an African uh so we have a
lot of different voices which gives it a
kind of global sense of course they're
all reading in English but it's it's
Global in that sense and it is a book
about a global problem it wasn't and it
wasn't always free right it's not a
re-release where you've kind of
positioned it this way so in fact yeah
it was initially published by random
house
um and at some point uh Charlie said
let's try and get the rights back so
that we can make it free so we had long
negotiations with random house we had to
pay for it um and I wasn't sure that
that was the best investment of our
funds given that we were trying to raise
funds to help save lives but Charlie
persuaded me that in the long run it
would save a lot more lives and because
we've now distributed far more copies of
the book than random has would have if
we left the rights for them and a lot of
people have read it
um and donated and in fact someone said
this book was free but it's actually the
most expensive book I've ever ever
because they donated significantly yeah
so um so yeah it has it has paid off
getting the rights back uh-huh and you
can the audiobook is that you could just
get it on Spotify like listen to it like
you would listen to a podcast just in
chapters you know that's right different
episodes which is pretty cool so it's
very easy to find you don't have to go
to audible or anything like that yep
that's right and if you prefer to read
in paper we are actually having uh
specially for for listeners to your
podcast we're um uh asking them to
donate and we're having matching funds
and uh uh they can we'll even uh mail a
paperback copy of the book to them if
they prefer that right uh I believe and
this is incredibly generous so here's
what everybody's watching or listening
is going to do you're going to go to the
life you can save dot org uh Slash
richroll and you can learn more about
the organization and where your funds
will be allocated uh if you donate there
uh the organization is going to match
you dollar for dollar up to twenty five
thousand dollars total right and you can
get the book there so that's pretty good
and incredibly generous so
check it out yeah thanks for the
opportunity to to reach your listeners I
think it's uh your listeners are the
kind of people who
I imagine a lot of them will want to
support this yeah and we hope to hear
from them yeah it's uh uh it's it's a
very special thing and you know I can't
first of all I can't thank you enough
for for taking time out of your Venture
back to Australia to spend time with me
today
um and I just uh I I hold you in the
highest regard and I think you're the
legacy of the work that you're doing is
just it's an extraordinary thing and I
can't tell you
um what an impact you've had on my life
and the life of millions and millions of
people it's just it's such a Worthy
um it's a worthy life well lived sir
that you that you you've walked a
certain path that I think is just
extraordinarily laudable and rare so
well thank you very much rich I I really
do appreciate that I know that we're
both working for a lot of the same
causes and we're both
trying to leave the world a better place
than it would have been if we hadn't
been here so I really appreciate your
words and what you're doing yeah thank
you so when uh the updated version of
animal Liberation is coming out in the
spring I think that's in in May yes yeah
okay well maybe you can come back here
and we can talk oh that would be one of
that would you rate itself thank you and
uh and I need the the phone number of
your surf instructor when I go to
Australia ah yes yes I'm talking about
surfing we haven't talked about surfing
no but I know you're going to Byron Bay
which is one of the most beautiful
places in Australia and uh I can put you
in touch with a former U.S surfing
champion who is a a great surfing guy
and a surfing Guru and either he or his
daughter will be very happy to get you
on a board in the way it's there
excellent well I'm holding you to it all
right thank you Peter cheers thanks for
these Lance
[Music]
thank you